here's how fast it happened right i mean
i was plugged into the matrix yesterday
morning
no days off baby writing stories about
stuff that's going on in the nfl
actually had written a story within an
hour earlier saying this impasse
continues until someone blinks
little did i know that arthur blank was
in the process of blinking
i take a break to go to the bathroom
he's going to the bathroom i went and i
come back and it's done
that fast boom bang pow so
anyway yes it was it was an exciting day
and we knew
that the titans were the team to watch
and we knew
that a second round pick would be the
maximum compensation notwithstanding
reports of a first round pick being in
play
those came with caveats that made it far
from a first round pick so at the end of
the day
it's julio jones plus a 2023
sixth round pick to the titans
for a second round pick in 2022
from tennessee to atlanta and a fourth
round pick in 2023
from tennessee to atlanta structure very
similar to the haydenhurst trade and
what the
and and chris this gets back to what
we've been saying all along
because the falcons got a second-round
pick for muhammad sunu
in 2019 from the patriots and they
turned around and sent that same second
round pick
55th overall in the 2020 draft to the
ravens for hayden hurst and it was
the second round pick plus a five for
hurst plus a four there was going to be
some extra compensation
after that second round pick to get this
thing done that's what it took peter
king breaks it down to football morning
in america it was gonna be more than a
two it wasn't gonna be a one
it was gonna be more than a two so it's
a two plus a future
four right for jones and a six and they
finally get the grains just right so it
balances out and the falcons say
all right let's be done with it yeah get
the grains right whatever whatever you
want to say
i mean yeah the falcons i'm sure they
still didn't love trading him
away for a second round pick and a
fourth you know because of the optics
like we talked about so i mean we're
going to unpack all of that we'll get to
that
but i mean i think the star of the show
is the tennessee titans and what they
acquired here
i mean come on the tennessee titans just
went from
playoff contender to you know playoff
contender
oh maybe they can make a run i don't
know
if they're a real super bowl contender
to now they're a full-fledged super bowl
contender i mean
that that's that's that's all they're
said to be you know that's all that
needs to be said
you know they've made adjustments on the
defensive side of the ball we saw that
you know had a pretty good draft but now
you add this formula here
it's hard for me to come up with a
formula really
you know this this when you just talk
about like weapons having to defend
i mean the things that come to my mind
right away okay and i understand these
are the great names in the pantheon of
the sport
but the formula is what makes sense to
me whether it's like
the cowboys with emmett smith and
michael irving and harper
or it was it john taylor roger craig and
jerry rice
i mean that's what kind of element we
have here but really i think almost
greater than that
you know really aj brown is definitely
one of the top 10 receivers of football
arguably top
five i think julio went healthy and
everything's good is still
right in the top five range so you talk
about that
with the number one running back in the
game i that's as
is as loaded as of a three as far as
talent is concerned
as i can remember it's up there with
with some of the greats in history at
least just from the pure talent in the
field
now they got to kind of you know show it
and prove it
the move has altered the betting markets
to a certain extent you see
it tennessee was up but not much plus
120
favorite to win the division before plus
110
after not a huge dump there
and the colts fall from actually they
were the favorites of plus 100 to plus
110 so it's even now between tennessee
and indianapolis
and you see there tennessee winning the
super bowl plus 3 500 down to plus 3
000.
julio jones is an mvp candidate down
from plus 15
000 plus 10 000 and then ryan tannehill
his
mvp candidacy increases because look you
got julio jones you got aj brown you got
derek henry and if the titans are a team
that emerges from the pack in the afc
competing for and maybe securing the one
seed we we say that every year
one of the mvps is likely to be the
quarterback of one of the one seeds yeah
that's right last year
one seed green bay aaron rodgers
mvp so uh you know either one
one seed or two seed from either
conference the quarterback of that team
ends up being a guy to watch for mvp and
wouldn't that be something if ryan
daniel ended up being the nfl mvp
after the dolphins gave him eight years
eight years to develop into a franchise
quarterback
the moment they trade him and pay five
million to make it happen
he becomes comeback player of the year
for the titans gets a big contract
now he's in a great position that's
right with the weapons
that he has and speaking of that
transaction from two years ago when the
dolphins had to pay five million dollars
of the tannehill compensation to
facilitate a trade to the titans
the titans didn't get that this time
around the falcons avoided paying
anything 15.3 million guaranteed for
skill injury and cap will be fully paid
by the titans this year
there's another two million dollar full
guarantee next year
38 million plus over three years that's
fully and completely the titans
obligation
falcons paying none of it and the other
big caveat too
if julio jones plays well this year he's
not playing for 38 million
over three years he's getting a raise or
at a minimum he's wanting a raise after
one season if not sooner chris
yeah i mean i i get it that's that's
part of the gamble here
of trading for for julio jones john
robinson
really smart guy i mean understands
football
i think he's probably looked at it and
understands that's that the writing's on
the wall there too
to where they feel comfortable about you
know what that might bring to them next
year or the year after
whatever they're gonna have to really
dig in and figure out a contract for
julio jones
but obviously they're comfortable with
it the risk was worth the reward to them
they just said wait the guy's still
really freaking talented
yeah wait let's do our homework let's
make sure he's still healthy
okay he's good um all right we can't
pass it up
it's it was a um i think a need for the
football team that was
real like there was a real spot for them
as far as having that needing that next
extra weapon
attention seeker whatever it is to make
their football team better
and i think the other thing too mike
where they just look at it and go
okay the risk all that type of stuff the
contract everything
i mean what it's gonna do for them
schematically the formula on the
football field mike i mean really
you got two legit number one receivers
on both sides of the ball
two type of guys where when teams play
atlanta
or the tennessee titans they want to put
safeties over the top of aj brown and
julio jones
right and yeah you can get away with it
one safety over the top of aj brown
without another weapon and okay we could
bring the other guy down and cheat away
to stop the run still and do that
now they're really going to put you in a
bind that's the beauty of it the way
they play football
it really fits and now teams are going
to have decisions to make to go
wait do we want to yeah i mean let's go
ryan tannehill's saying right i mean i'm
sure he was doing cartwheels and
backflips and everything else
because he's he they're gonna have
packages at the line of scrimmage mike
the defense isn't gonna be right i mean
they're just not gonna be able to be
right
oh oh you're coming down to stop the run
oh we got one on one with aj brown and
julio jones outside
well good night i'm ryan tannehill i
throw the ball down the field really
well we're just gonna pick you apart
oh wait now you want to protect it you
know play coverage
you're worried about the big plays well
here comes the old sledgehammer number
22 between the tackles
so it's really smart from that sense
it's a good player
it really is a system fit and i think
they figured
they're that close and that one player
away from really being in the thick of
things here and that's why john robinson
does it and takes on those things you're
talking about
there have been times where we've been
spitting with the concept of
triplets but some teams whether it be
the colts with peyton manning
the greatest show-offs on turf it's not
just quarterback running back receiver
it's quarterback running back
two great exactly and now the titans
enter that group and it doesn't happen
very often
no where everything lines up just right
where you have
great quarterback great running back
great receivers two of them
you got four guys that can create havoc
and it's gonna be pick your poison
every time we see that right comes to
pick your poison proposition the offense
gets souped up and this is what
aj brown said yesterday via the titans
website all the way up through college
julio's been my favorite receiver
someone i've always looked up to just
having someone like that in the locker
room now that i can just ask what do i
need to do here it's great
we talk all the time anyway but having
someone that close and to see it on the
field firsthand for yourself
it's great i have a picture in my locker
of julio and i ask myself every day
before i go out to practice don't let
julio outwork you
because that's how i measure myself up
to the best receiver in the game
to have him on the same team as me it's
going to raise my level of play which is
great and it is
it is that's why he was out there with
those videos right he knows
if julio jones shows up all of a sudden
aj brown's not getting as much attention
as he used to aj brown becomes a guy who
gets
open aj brown becomes a guy who can set
up for himself the kind of contract
that he wants when the window opens
after this season you know we talked
about the seahawks right into a mess you
got dk metcalf coming up for a contract
after this year
julio is going to want a new contract
same deal in tennessee
you got aj brown coming up for a
contract after this year and julio is
going to want to get paid if he doesn't
get paid on his way through the door
that's something the titans are going to
have to that's something they're gonna
have to figure out yeah
that that that to me like obviously they
felt
okay with the the julio thing and all
that but yeah i mean
yes you're gonna have two guys that are
top ten receivers in football
that are gonna be ready for new
contracts and we know that
that can be an issue so uh i don't know
john robinson obviously feels
comfortable about where they are in that
situation but you're right that's going
to be
a tough one to balance it really is
other thing i wanted to say i mean
i mean you either talk all the time see
there there that goes too we talk all
the time so he knew he knew how bad
julio wanted to be in tennessee
and all of those type of things i don't
think i realized really that original
video where he goes through the players
as the picture i don't i think i missed
that he was wearing the julio jones
jersey
in that in there with the the tape
around it and number eight
but yeah you know obviously listen
there's a lot of similarities between
the player
they're both jacked and specimens and
they're similar in their skill set you
know i'm not going to say aj brown's
quite julio jones julio is a really
really really special
like wide receiver but aj brown's really
really damn good too
and just again with the way they fit
it's like mike it's like we talked about
with a lot of these great offenses
whether it goes back to like you're
talking about you know the colts with
reggie wayne and marvin's harrison
you're not going to be able to pin
either guy to like one aspect of the
offense oh this guy goes short
and this guy goes deep or this guy runs
the routes and this guy just runs
straight routes
no they're both going to do that they
both run block
they're both physical that way they're
both willing to go over the middle after
a play action pass and do
that type of stuff so really like from
the football standpoint it makes so much
sense
and then i think from the culture
standpoint it makes a lot of sense here
too
i mean it really does and it's a team
that was close and you know i love it
they just basically
they they had a you know a few chips in
the pile in the middle
and they went all in this weekend and
said all right that's it we feel like
we're pretty damn good we've made some
moves in the off season
draft was good we're close we're
actually just this guy away
here we go we're coming after the super
bowl in 2021 and i love it
and aj brown did make it clear that
despite his admiration of julio jones he
is not giving up number 11.
number eight that that we've seen so far
hey look somebody'd have to pay for all
those
aj brown number 11 jerseys at retail
if aj brown changes his number and gives
julio
number 11 and meanwhile any falcons fan
that may have bought number 11 in recent
weeks
sorry you're not going to get your money
back although i think they have some
sort of a
some sort of plan with fanatics that if
a guy's traded
there is some sort of jersey guarantee i
don't know
i would suggest looking into that if you
have purchased a julio
jones jersey at any point in the last 60
or 90 days because
obviously now uh he ain't with the
falcons anymore
let's hear from john robinson about the
transaction we've we've praised the
titans we're praising him
let's hear what he had to say about it
because i got a point chris i want to
make on the other side here's robinson
regarding the trade that brings julio
jones to nashville
excited to add julio to the football
team um
he's he's excited to be a part of of
what we've got going on here in
nashville
and um it's a big day for our team we've
been talking jim for probably
um you know two three uh two or three
weeks here
uh back and forth with with atlanta and
terry fontenot down there and
uh my hat's off to him it's just this is
his first
uh big trade he was great to work with
um
but uh he's got a great career ahead of
him uh so i appreciate working with him
and dealing with him
but we had discussions um really you
know kind of back and forth for the last
couple weeks kind of picked up in
intensity a little bit
uh yesterday uh and then finally found
some closure this morning on it and
um able to agree uh to the terms on it
whatever the
value is is is the value and we felt
like it was
it was good value for us and atlanta
felt like it was good value for for them
obviously or they wouldn't have done the
trade um you know they're excited and
we're excited
separately chris peter king spoke to
john robinson yesterday
and he asked robinson about
the health issue with julio jones the
fact that he missed
seven games last year with a hamstring
injury
robinson told peter that that was big in
the decision missing time last year what
were the circumstances surrounding that
based on our evaluation of him he's
healthy
and it doesn't look like he's lost
anything to us
this gets back to the point that we've
been making and it's a point that you
have to make delicately because i'm not
accusing julio jones of anything this is
a reality of modern football he's not
the first to do it
he won't be the last that hamstrings got
a little grab in it's got a little pull
it's got a little tweak
sorry i can't go today yeah that's right
that's what you hear from a guy who
isn't happy
guys happy guy feels like he's properly
paid guys feel like guy feels like
everything's in a good place feels like
his efforts are
right team's not in the playoff race
yeah then
then i'll get out there and i'll play
and i'll risk future and further injury
so
i i think that was that was how you
reconcile it's not something they're
going to articulate
because it is you know it's not exactly
the way you want to welcome julio jones
into the team hey no he's healthy trust
no he was faking it those last he was
faking he was embellishing
right last year right we're we're fine
with that because we think he really was
healthy
it's you can't say that but i think
that's what
the titans have concluded chris i i i
mean it sounds like
obviously they're very comfortable with
that and i mean i hear what you're
saying there i kind of i hear it too
i thought you were right from that point
from the get-go that it
you know listen if they were in a super
bowl run and things like that yeah then
maybe you might have saw him but
yeah with the circumstances he was in
and it's not 100
i'm not going to test it let me just see
where it goes for all the reasons you
explain
like i'm with you there and mike i mean
again too
like you know oh we did all our research
and all that stuff hey listen when i
think any team says that
i mean listen i just know too many
stories of like oh well
you know we knew he was going to be
working out at this park in atlanta
at this time and oh we just happened to
have somebody there across the street
not at the field of valium they just
happened to be
across the street and they got to see
him work out and go well his hamstring
looks pretty good i just happened to be
walking by that park in atlanta and
there was julio jones it was the
craziest thing ever
i mean listen i i can't you know tell on
people but i
i know 15 20 of those stories over the
last 20 years of my life
and the nfl so i would think there's
some real inside knowledge to the health
of julio jones as to what you're saying
and and would agree with you there so
that that's where they feel comfortable
about it
and you know at base level hey it does
look like the tennessee titans won the
trade of course it does they got a first
ballot hall of famer a guy that's still
you know on the outside edge of his
prime and playing really good football
and yes it's a second and a fourth round
pick for a guy that just pushed a team
into the super bowl window so
yeah it looks like they won this one for
sure but you know i don't know if it's
quite as easy as that because there's a
lot of other circumstances that play
into this
one of the other angles that came up
yesterday once we saw that the titans
are getting julio jones for a two and a
four and they're also getting a six
back so it's not a straight two and a
four yeah and
and this is how you find out who does
and doesn't
pay attention every day to the nfl
and primarily to the nfl because people
were surprised
that oh that that's all they're getting
well haven't you been following the
story
for the last six weeks yeah that's all
they're getting
they wanted more they weren't getting
more they're getting a two
and they were lucky to get more than a
two they finally blinked and if you
follow it closely primarily at pft
you know all that you're not surprised
by but plenty of people in the media
yes and players were surprised when they
saw the final terms now look i don't
expect the players
to follow this stuff every single day
that's right every single day not many
do
but you know if you're if you're a
zealous fan or if you're in the media
you should not be
surprised by the idea that it was a two
and a four and jalen ramsey's
comments really struck me i'm surprised
no one had explained to him
what was going on especially since he's
one of the reasons why they couldn't go
get
jayla rams there's only so many big
ticket items you can go
buy at the store before you run out of
money chris yeah that's right i mean
it's just
i mean they've you know first round
picks high contracts everything like
that the rams it's it's not that easy
you know and yes i know at base level
the value doesn't look right
for a guy that we're talking about like
this who's you know
on the edge of a top five receiver or
top ten definitely a top ten
in the nfl type of talent it does
but like it's it's it's it's not about
it like it's not about the players we've
just we've talked and we've tried to
explain to people you know yeah
i think people that didn't really pay
attention to the nuts and bolts of the
situation and players don't always pay
attention to that stuff
they just see julio jones he's got to be
worth the first round pick
and they just chalk it up to that in
their brain oh they'll figure it out at
some point he'll get traded for a first
round pick and i think that's really
what the casual fan
thinks too but no like you know it's not
about the player it's about the market
it's about the need and that's where it
was off
for atlanta and that's where i don't
look at atlanta and go oh this was a bad
trade
i'm going to kind of put a look at it
and go no their timing was bad
everything like that was bad how they
planned it was bad
for the situation the way it is right
now i don't blame them
for doing what they had to do yeah
they're getting in like you know
scary unchartered water waters here oh
what do you
they don't want to bring julio jones to
camp and have to pay the 15 million
dollars
in case he gets hurt or something like
that so it's all scary that way
so that's where you know that's where i
think you know some of the people that
don't pay attention
totally are kind of lost with that a
little bit
and that's where to me atlanta dropped
the ball not about right now
but how they planned this out and when
they should have really
been aggressive to try to trade julio
jones well and look part of it too
was that there had been long-standing
dysfunction between
jones and the falcons going back at
least three years from the moment
after ryan got a contract that pays out
30 million per year
and julio had one that paid 15 and he
said
essentially what's wrong with this
picture that guy isn't worth two dollars
for every one dollar i get
and he embarked on an effort to get more
and ultimately got more
got more without holding out at the 2018
start of training camp got to 22 million
per year
in new money average that still
didn't quite mend the fence and
maybe if we had known more about what
was going on at the time and they did a
great job
of keeping it under wraps julio jones
discreet by nature
not a guy that's going to go air out
dirty laundry the falcons like every
other team don't want that stuff out
there they handled their business
privately but chris
that's when it becomes a disadvantage to
a team
exactly when you do trade him for what
the average
casual drive-by fan or media member
would look at and say
whoa whoa exactly second round picture
right
i thought i heard espn say there was a
first shot exactly
right yeah right and that's that's where
it hurt the falcons too look
i firmly believe from talking to people
around the league that the falcons were
deliberately leaking
incomplete information in an effort to
try to get that first round pick
and that the only first round pick that
was ever on the table
had as much as a second round pick
attached to julio jones
hey falcons you want a first round pick
fine you got to give us julio and a two
if you want a first round pick that bad
yeah
that part of it didn't come out right
right and it creates the expectation
they're gonna get a first round pick
so they went all in yeah telling a half
truth
right to try to get that first round
pick and and it didn't work
and and that contributes that's where
you need to understand
how your strategy and your tactics for
getting what you want
are potentially going to blow up from a
pr standpoint
because there are going to be people
look at and say what the hell is wrong
with the falcons they get a second round
pick for one of the best receivers in
the history of the game
no no doubt about it they kind of set
that expectation by trying to push the
market that way you're right
and now it's a failed expectation to the
casual fan who doesn't really
maybe understand that and it's really
only going to get worse i could say that
you know again i i don't think i don't
look at atlanta and going this is a bad
trade
no i don't i mean it's going to get
worse because julio is going to get
1200 yards receiving next year and go to
the pro bowl
and the titans are going to be one of
the top three seeds and everyone's going
to make
a social media joke about they got this
guy for a second round pick
it's going to be which is basically a
third round pick yeah it's going to
exactly it's going to become a a joke i
mean it is it's going to become an
online media type of joke that way and
that's to me where all the things you
explain mike
julio jones three years ago all those
type of things
we discussed this a little during the
season last year right mike
i mean i know before the trade deadline
we discussed i know i was saying if i'm
atlanta i'm looking to trade julio jones
the era of this team is over it's time
to restart and do a new one i know i was
one of the guys saying that we had a lot
of discussions about that
yep that's where they dropped the ball
cap hit cap hit was too big too big
it only got to a point when june 2 came
around this year right that pit was
manageable
and maybe they would have done it last
year uh if they could have gotten more
than the second round pick they got for
muhammad sununu that's a new trade and
the haydenhurst trade
it hurts just screwed things up it got
arthur blank
to dig in and i look
i was told a week or so ago they could
have had a second round pick
with no financial obligation to pay any
of his salary and they won't pay any of
his salary we've already said that
um they could have had that at the time
of the draft it still would have been
2022 because the trade couldn't happen
until june 2.
but there really was a question whether
they were going to find something as
good as what they could have had around
the time of the draft
once all these teams go out and spend
first and second round picks on
receivers
they should be happy that they got more
than a straight to and not having to pay
the julio jones salary because there
were people who thought they weren't
going to get
even that much so and and that's where
you have to ask yourself as an
organization how far
down the dirty laundry rabbit hole do we
want to go
now and make it clear our hands were
tied all right
right we had no choice right this
relationship was off the rails and if
the falcons are smart they'll find a way
yes once it's all final once it's done
to to without
without making their guy look bad
but to make it clear that this was an
untenable situation the time had come to
move on we did what we had to do
i think they're trusting people in the
media who get it to blow that
mega horn is that how megaphone blow
that horn blow oh god it's a
it's a similar sims ism blow that horn
mega horn that megaphone the mega horn
baby i like it mega horn
i think it works i bet the mega horn is
a thing
but i think they're counting on those of
us who get it to say
hey people people calm down calm down
look
they this is the best they could have
that's the best this relationship
was as fractured as aaron rodgers in
green bay
and other situations where we say those
two can't co-exist much longer yeah it
was over
there's no doubt that's why i'll
continue to say for right now this was
this is a good deal i'm not mad at
atlanta the one thing i just questioned
like two to added to like the trade
deadline last year which of course is
not this current regime
so i'm not trying to blame anybody there
right and i understand the old regime is
you know trying to hold on to oh maybe
we could save our jobs and
make this work the interim regime morris
is trying to earn that job
right exactly so there's there's
reluctance there
but where i will question it is maybe
why there wasn't more conversations or
more of an aggressive approach
earlier in the offseason and i don't
know all the back
stories there maybe they're maybe this
wasn't figured out maybe julio didn't
say i definitely want out there i'm not
trying to accuse
but i'm just saying like in the world of
maximization for your
trade and value and all that you know
getting back to that conversation
like we've discussed if we got into this
right at the start of free agency and
things like that
they might have gotten something closer
to what they wanted to where yeah you
get a
trade going there you could you could
wait to get the particulars done so
still
june 2nd to figure out the financial
issues and everything
like that but you have all the teams
there that are still wait
we don't have a free agent receiver we
haven't hit the draft yet whoa julio
jones is available
wow we like him better than any free
agent receiver and of course he's a
proven commodity who's better than
anybody in the draft so we like that a
lot
that's when they could have really
maximized that to me would be the big
question i would want to ask atlanta
and go why wasn't this done three months
ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports